I don't want to put words in Anthony's
mouth by the way and I like him today I
walk in I hear I'm gonna fire him I'm
not firing I think he's a wonderful guy
we probably said fire i retweeted
somebody Peugeot
they said fire doesn't matter did you
notice that when they retweeted
everything that somebody's opinion oh
that is a pinion and you know I was
thought about that I said I'm not firing
effective you ask your friends in the
office and the public relations office I
was immediately called upon that and I
said no I like him I think he's terrific
because this was a person's view not
everybody's happy with Anthony not
everybody's happy with everybody but I
will tell you we have done a job the
likes of which nobody has ever done the
mobilization getting of equipment all of
the things we've done nobody's ever done
a job like this we have 50 governors and
territories by the way people don't ever
mention that we have territories we have
50 governors and territories and many of
those governors are Democrats and they
can't find anything to complain about
and honestly many of them didn't do
their jobs I'll let you know someday
let's see what happens but I make let
you know who's not doing their job I can
tell you the ones that are good both
Republican and Democrat and the ones who
don't know what they're doing but we
helped some of the ones that don't know
what they're doing they should have had
their own stockpiles and now if they
want we can build them stockpiles of
ventilators the hardest thing as a
ventilator because it's expensive it
takes a while to get we got him and
nobody believed we did now many of the
governors were asking for far too many
and we said they were asking for far too
many we talked and we said you said very
strongly that they just don't need that
me you said they don't need that many
beds Debra so that's it receive good
yeah what happened from the beginning I
don't know what it is exactly but if I
put somebody's opinion up you don't I
don't mind controversy I think
controversy is a good thing not a bad
thing but I want it to be honest
controversy now when I got a call I got
a call not very quickly and nobody you
know saw that as being any big deal
they said how are you doing with dr.
Fatih I said I'm doing great
and I didn't talk to dr. fetcher even or
until we just got here
dr. foul she asked one of the people if
he could get up and speak and he did and
they totally misinterpreted him I saw
what they did he said the question was
hypothetical but what he was just
acknowledging is that lives would have
been saved if the mitigation practices
were put into place earlier that seems
obvious do you not agree with that
yes I know what he really is saying
though but how could you have done it
look I just went over stats with you
right here right here how do you close
it up you have no deaths and no cases on
January 11th doctor would you recommend
closing the United States of America oh
this must be terrible how many cases do
we have none how many deaths do we have
none January 17th go back another week
on January 17th this is ten days before
I did the little bit less than ten days
before I did the band I did a ban on
China you think that was easy I didn't
did a ban on Europe and a lot of people
said that was an incredible thing to do
because you look at Spain and by the way
we're doing very well because when you
look at all of those flat graphs and you
add it all up the United States is very
low and per capita were very low we're
doing very well but how do you close up
the United States of America so on
January 6 no deaths on January 11th know
this and note no cases on January 17th
no cases no cases no deaths I'm supposed
to close up the United States of America
when I have no cases the middle of March
should you close the valve close down
from China excuse me I closed it down
from China and by the way some people
think I should have waited longer and
maybe written it out I disagree with
them okay but it was thought up I mean
that was an alternative you know there
are a lot of people that would have said
let's write it out now I'll give you the
good news if I would have done that it
would have been I think catastrophic
because their numbers are anthing 1.6 to
2.2 million people would have died if we
tried to do that
and I did this last time cut it in half
don't say 2.2 million cut it in more
than half say a million people died well
that's much more than the Civil War cut
it in half take the million and cut it
in half that's 500,000 people would have
died now that number we would have
reached okay that would have been easy
to reach if we did nothing so we did the
right thing and our timing was very good
but here's the one thing and you have to
say this when you ask me why didn't you
do this how come when I did the ban on
China and some very very institute as
some very tough things
how come Nancy Pelosi a month later is
in Chinatown saying let's all March this
is not going to happen how come we have
many of the experts from CNN and many
other networks if you call CNN a network
I don't personally but we have CNN we
have many other places and they're all
saying he doesn't need to do it he
doesn't need to do it all I'm saying is
this how do you close down the greatest
economy in the history of the world when
on January 17th
you have no cases and no death when on
January 21st you have one case and no
death one case think of that now we're
supposed to close out of the country but
here's what happened when on January
31st I instituted the ban
Joe Biden went crazy he said you don't
need the band you he didn't go crazy
like he just he didn't even know what
the hell the ban was but he so he didn't
go crazy but he did say he did call me
Xenophon wait a minute
he called me xenophobic he called me a
racist because he has since apologized
and he said I did the right thing so
when you say why didn't you this every
Democrat thought I made a mistake when I
did it I saved tens of thousands maybe
hundreds of thousands of lives paper
that you bought the argument is that you
bought yourself some time you didn't you
just to prepare hospitals you didn't use
it
Ramba testing right so you so you so
disgraceful it's so disgraceful the way
you said it
let me just listen I just went over it
nobody thought we should do it and what
I did it what do you do when you have no
case in a whole United States when you
hear excuse me
you reported it zero cases zero deaths
On January 17 or January 30 and in fact
we'll give you a list what we did in
fact part of it was up there we did a
lot look you know you're a fake you know
that your whole network the way you
cover it is fake and most of it and not
all of you but the people are wise to
you that's why you have a lower lower
approval rating than you've ever had
before times probably three and when you
ask me that question
let me ask you this why did invitin why
didn't why did Biden apologize why did
he write a letter of apology okay oh
that's very important why did the
Democrats think that I acted too quickly
you know why because they really thought
that I acted too quickly we have done a
great job now I could've I could have
kept it open and I could have done what
some countries are doing they're getting
beat up pretty badly I could have kept
it open I thought of keeping it open
because nobody's ever heard of closing
down a country let alone the United
States of America but if I would have
done that we would have had hundreds of
thousands of people that would right now
be dead we've done this right and we
really we really have done this right
the problem is the press doesn't cover
it the way it should be